thanks for being here I am very excited
to be talking to you all about unison it
is a new programming language with kind
of special support for building
distributed systems this is joint work
that I've been doing with my awesome
colleagues Aria who is in the audience
here and also my other colleague ruin
our who just had a baby and a bunch of
awesome open source contributors and
I'll flash up their names at the end of
the talk so what is unison so it is a
open source statically typed functional
language very much influenced by a few
languages haskell Erlang and this
research language that's very
interesting called Frank unison itself
has been sort of a research project for
several years now but I would say the
past year or so you've really been
focused on trying to turn it into
something real that you could use for
real stuff and we are almost there
we are currently alpha testing our very
first release which is super exciting it
is a public alpha and I'll I'll say how
you can participate in that if you're
interested at the end of the talk so
what's sort of the motivation here like
why why another programming language so
I mean in general just I love
programming I've been doing it for about
20 years and I feel like the essence of
it is it's so much fun it's captivating
you know I'm excited to go to work every
day and but there's also many aspects of
programming that are sort of not as fun
that feel like needlessly arcane or
complicated and really wanted to just
kind of design a new language really
starting from first principles being
willing to rethink anything and
everything about how programming
currently works and see if it was
possible to create something better and
[Music]
so so that's sort of like overall kind
of the guiding philosophy I guess behind
unison but then there actually is one
very specific core technical idea that
the language is sort of based around and
I want to sort of share that idea and
explain it clearly and then show sort of
all the benefits that we're getting from
from building on this idea in unison and
it's kind of a simple idea it's actually
not it's not really a new idea although
no one has really tried to build a
programming language around this before
so these these next two slides are like
the most important slides of the talk I
think so because we're gonna be like
building building on them but so what
what's the core idea it's in unison
we're going to identify definitions not
by their name but by a hash of their
content so if we define a function
factorial factorial then is equal to the
product of the numbers 1 through n it
actually doesn't matter whether we call
that function factorial or whether we
call it blah it doesn't matter whether
we call the parameter n or whether we
call it Z it's the same function and we
can compute a content hash of the
implementation of that function and
let's say that hash is whatever j1e okay
in reality these are going to be 512 bit
sha-3 hashes okay but I'm not going to
show those in the slides for all these
reasons okay so okay so we're we say
that the code is content addressed it's
identified by its content and we're
actually going to do something different
what and when we store the code in a in
a unison code base so rather than
storing a unison code base just as a
collection of text files where the text
is just this completely unprocessed form
of your program right so instead of that
what we're actually going to store is
for each hash we're going to store its
serialized abstract syntax tree
so a very processed form of the code
that's sort of easy to manipulate and do
things with so here's this is this is
not the exact unison code based format
but this asserting gives you the basic
idea so we have a dot unison directory
and then within that we have a
subdirectory one for each hash so our
factorial function we have a directory
for that hash and then within that
directory we have this AST file which is
a serialized form of the of the
factorial program and then very
important is that separately from the
the ast is we are storing the names or
the name of that definition so the names
just sort of separately stored metadata
so we're saying this hash has the name
factorial and it also has the name law
and maybe it has 50 other names too and
then we would have the same kind of
structure for other definitions in a
unison code base so what's actually in
this serialized syntax tree so if you
look at the definition of factorial it's
actually referenced as three
dependencies it's referencing product
it's referencing the function range and
it's referencing the function plus so
what's actually stored in the syntax
tree is not those names it's actually
the hashes of product range and plus and
then when we actually compute the Unison
hash for factorial we do some further
normalization so you know we normalized
what what the names of local variables
are before we compute the hash so okay
bottom line the these unison hashes
unlike names they uniquely identify the
exact in particular definition that
we're interested in so the the hash of
factorial it it uniquely identifies
factorial
and it pins down the exact versions of
all of its dependencies so it's like an
unambiguous way of referring to a
particular piece of code and so that's
an idea that we're gonna be building on
so I guess
show of hands like there are those tea
slides like pretty clear raise your hand
if that's like clear okay cool great
alright so that's it that's the idea
that's unison okay okay so seems it
doesn't seem like much right but uh
we're gonna get all these benefits by
building on this idea in unison so first
sort of thing is we're gonna get a
really nice story for doing code base
management so we're not gonna have
builds anymore we're gonna be able to do
renames trivially we're gonna be able to
cache test results we're gonna have to
keep running the same tests over and
over we're gonna eliminate dependency
conflicts as a thing that won't be
something we have to worry about anymore
we're gonna get a nice story for doing
for having typed durable storage without
any sort of boilerplate of like writing
JSON encoders and decoders and then kind
of the the domain that was sort of a
motivation for for this design decision
in the first place is we'll be able to
have unison programs that describe
entire elastic distributed systems and
which you know deploy themselves at
runtime as they're executing on to you
know thousands of nodes that's okay
that's not done yet but that's where
we're going okay okay so I'll make it
clear like what's actually implemented
now versus what's in the pipeline but ok
cool so let's actually I'm basically
gonna spend the rest of this talk going
through these benefits and seeing how
they emerge from that one design
decision of content a dress code let's
look at renames first this is kind of an
easy one so because we're storing the
name separately from the syntax tree
it's really easy
just replace that name with something
else if we want to say rename factorial
to transmogrify we just say okay great
we'll get rid of that factorial file and
add a transmogrify file and boom the
function has been renamed so very
important is that first of all we are
not behind the scenes doing you know a
whole bunch of text manipulation on
behalf of the user
to make this happen we really we really
are just updating that name in one place
which is cool but even better than that
is that this doesn't actually break
anyone's code including like our
downstream library users who may not
even know about it right so right now if
you publish the library and you decide
you want to rename a function in that
library you know you're you're basically
on your next release you're gonna break
all your users code and that's really
unfortunate so because because the ast
is referring to things by hash you can
move things around rename them you know
and it doesn't break anyone who's
depending on your code which is a really
nice property okay that's cool right I
think that's cool that was like you know
it's it's it's one of these things where
if you're designing a system today and
you asked would you rather have that or
would you rather have what we have now
it's sort of like well this is clearly
an improvement so it's just so nice easy
one that we're getting okay so another
thing is that we don't have builds
anymore
so once we've added factorial to our
code base that definition never changes
it just is and so we never need to parse
or type check that definition ever again
and when we're writing say a tests that
is referencing factorial we are just
going to look up the type of factorial
and just pass that to the type checker
when we're just type checking just this
one little snippet of code that we're
Dibley editing so generally and also
during this during the demo its you're
never really going to be waiting around
for the compiler to process you know
hundreds of text files just to type
check parts and type check your code and
so the way we do that is we actually
just also alongside that hash we store
the ast and then we also store what was
the type of this definition and then the
type checker just can just look that up
and and you know type check the just the
new code that we're writing and then
also very important is that this isn't
just a sort of ephemeral state of your
IDE that's doing some like incremental
caching it really is that as soon as
anyone has written factorial and added
it to the codebase and shared it no one
else in the world who obtains that
definition needs to parse or type check
factorial either because it is part of
the use and code base format okay
another thing we can do is we can
actually cache test results so unison is
a functional language it doesn't just
allow sort of unrestricted side effects
and so and unit tests do not have access
to i/o of course you could write
integration tests that do i oh but unit
tests don't have access to i/o and so
they are by definition going to be
deterministic they're always going to
yield the same results so if factorial 5
equals 120 now it's going to continue to
equal 120 you know forevermore
and so we can just cash that test
results and the way we do that is just
associated with the hash we might keep
the AST the type and hey what was the
results of evaluating this hash okay so
we're getting all these nice properties
and it's really because of this general
idea that the code base is append-only
so we're only ever
so nothing is ever changing we're never
modifying or mutating definition we're
only ever introducing new definitions
and because because nothing is mutating
we can cache all sorts of auxilary
information and associate it with these
hashes and we don't need to worry about
it sort of complex cache invalidation
logic like what your IDE has to do to
kind of maintain a compilation cache
well these text files are being mutated
out from under it all the time which is
super complicated so we kind of are
sidestepping a lot of that complexity
okay so all right now for the scary part
I'm actually gonna try to give a demo of
this and but first of all like
discovering those like you know six
slides or what our worth of information
was was just like a completely
mind-blowing experience just to see that
all these things just sort of emerged
and has been really cool it's been a
really cool project to work on as a
result so all right let's let's move to
a demo here
how many do it on time okay
[Music]
so I have here on the right hand side I
have and is that pretty legible the font
is it big enough a little bigger darker
light on the left side like that all
right I'll try just bigger sorry all
right
okay so on the right-hand side here I
have the Unison tool and we call this
the unison code-based manager it's the
thing it's sort of this all-in-one tool
for running unison code working with the
unison code base you know renaming
things doing refactorings parsing type
checking code and then on the left hand
side I just have my favorite text editor
vim you can use whatever text editor you
want and I guess I'll sort of show a few
things here so one of the things that so
the code base is in this nicely process
form where we know the type of
everything and it's very structured and
so we have you know a lot of interesting
like useful things that we can do so if
I want to just do a search for some
definition I might you know say list tab
complete and then so you can sort of
search for definitions this way look
them up by type I could even do it type
based search find me definitions that
have this type a take a natural number
and a list and return a list and it
tells me okay there's actually two
functions take and drop so we can build
up all these like indices on the code
and just sort of maintain that in a very
straightforward way which is cool so
another thing that the that unison is
doing is it's actually watching for
changes to these dot u files in the
current directory we call these scratch
files because they're just kind of
places where you scribble down some code
and once you get it working you add it
to the code base and then maybe even
just delete the scratch file because now
the now the data is in the
bass and it's all good so if I if I save
the file it sort of picks that up right
away and says okay there's nothing there
but let's go ahead and you know add a
definition and it'll parse and type
check the file anything below these
triple dashes is we call that the fold
it's going to just be ignored
it's like commented out so any line that
starts with this greater than we call
that a watch expression it's going to be
evaluated on every file save if I so you
notice like sometimes that arrow is red
and then if I save it again
it is now gray so unison will actually
cache those watch expressions so you
know they're not going to be reevaluated
every time so it's like you should never
feel like oh I can't save the file
because it's gonna redo this huge
computation it's just going to sort of
cache it based on that that hash okay so
so these watch expressions are kind of
replace a traditional like read eval
print loop you just kind of like write
code and then interactively evaluate
different expressions so let's go ahead
and define factorial and I'll give a
couple test cases too so first of all
define product it's by folding the
numbers starting with one multiplying
them together and I might check okay
product that seems to be doing what I
expect and like so once once I'm happy
with the definition notice this message
these new definitions are okay to add so
I'm going to type the add command and it
says okay I've added these definitions
so now the the syntax tree of product is
in the code base and I could view it
and I can all these commands have
tab-completion so that's kind of helpful
view it and it'll it'll render that
syntax tree with import statements
inserted you know the most sort of
accurate precise import statement so you
can be kind of sloppy about your imports
because that's not actually part of your
that's not actually part of what's
stored in the code base so one thing and
then once once it's in the code base I
might just know just delete it it's
still there I could get it back if I if
I wanted to get that back like basically
dump it back to the scratch file so I
can look at it or make changes to it you
know can type that edit command but you
know I'm happy that it's there so I'm
just gonna leave it there one thing I
was going to point out is okay if we
look at product it uses this function
full bail and if we wanted to rename
full bail - I don't know if Rodney Cate
and then we view product again you'd see
it picks up that new name for full del
okay but I kind of like the name full
bail better so I'm just gonna undo that
and it shows me the diff of you know
what was just undone you can also view
the history of you know explore the
changes you've made there it's very
semantic it's sort of not showing these
textual diffs it's showing like okay
this definition was changed or this
thing was renamed okay cool so let's
define factorial and yep it's the
product of the numbers 1 through n and
I'm gonna just define some tests also
using watch expressions these are called
test watch expressions they start with
tests instead of just a single greater
than and I just have a few examples here
which I saved the file everything type
checks you can see the tests pass and
they're actually cashed why are they
cashed it's because I ran through this
example earlier
so they just happen to already be in the
test cache and once I'm sort of happy
with this I can add factorial and its
tests to the code base and I'll go ahead
and just even delete those those
definitions now if I run that if I run
the tests it's not actually running
anything it's just looking up those
already computed test results in the
cache and even if I rename the function
that's being tested like I rename
factorial to blah and I run the tests
again it's still just not actually doing
anything because the test cache is keyed
by the Unison hash so renaming doesn't
affect any of that caching cool and then
I guess one last example that I was
going to show is uh so I later in the
talk I'm gonna show like a really simple
distributed merge sort implementation
and I just wanted to show that rather
than like switching back and forth again
it's a distributed sort merge sort
function and I'm just running it locally
sort of simulating execution locally and
I'll show the actual source code for
this on a slide later but anyway so this
is kind of the basic sort of environment
it's kind of low-tech you know you have
your text editor you've got unison
running and you know you just sort of
write code it's very interactive and
it's it's nice all right cool so what
are some other benefits of this idea of
content address code so I said that
we're gonna eliminate dependency
conflicts so dependency conflicts they
arise when you have a gentleman you have
diamonds in the dependency graph so
suppose I'll explain what that means
okay so we have Alice she's written a
library has some definitions in it has
an employee type it has some function
in it and Bob and Carol are making use
of that library maybe Bob works in HR
and so he needs access to the employee
type and maybe Carol works in accounting
and she's you know also needs access to
some of the definitions from running
reports or whatever and then Dave wants
to make use of Bob and Carols libraries
so this is a diamond dependency because
shaped like a diamond
okay so this by itself is not a problem
the problem the diamond dependency
problem is when Carol and Bob may have
different ideas about which version of
Alice's library they want to use and
maybe Carol wants to use Alice version
two because it has some newfangled new
functionality and Bob still wants to use
version one and in a real programming
language ecosystem you know these
situations can be very common and it you
know can generate to result in all kinds
of problems and it's like oh my gosh we
have a dependency conflict like what do
we do everybody stop stop what you're
doing like we need to like resolve the
situation and get everybody to agree on
like which version of Alice's library
we're going to use globally across this
entire code base okay so but okay let's
breathe take a step back okay what what
are these clonk what are these so-called
conflicts really like what what are they
really about so they are I would say
they are caused by the fact that all of
our libraries have to occupy a single
shared namespace where you cannot have
multiple definitions sharing the same
name so like for basically artificial
reasons you can't have Alice version
ones notion of employee in the same
codebase
conveniently with Alice version twos
notion of employee because you know
they're the same type
because they're named the same thing
except they're not the same type there
are different types and if we just had a
reliable way of consistently referring
to types like say a hash a Content hash
then it would be perfectly fine to allow
as many different versions of the same
library in our code base and basically
there's no issue so so that's what
that's what unison does and it's I guess
to give like maybe some intuition for
like how this is not a problem it's sort
of similar to suppose you had to email
types floating around in your codebase
and they have different call up fully
qualified names you know that might be
totally fine if those two email types
are being used in like different parts
of your codebase it's like no big deal
maybe if those two email types are like
coming together in the same piece of
code you may have to write a killer
function to convert from one to the
other maybe you would decide like hey
let's kind of standardize on an email
type because we're like using you know
using it all over the place and like
it'd be easier to just have one but the
point is that it's not really a conflict
it's just sort of like a thing that you
may choose to do something about and
it's definitely not something that's
prevents you from from getting work done
like what might occur if you have
suddenly have a dependency conflict in
some of the libraries that you're trying
to work with okay cool
so easy typed durable storage this one's
kind of near and dear to my heart so
okay you're writing some code you've got
some data you want to save that data and
read it back later so what maybe it's a
list of employees okay and so what do we
do right now it's like list of employee
that's like this nice typed structured
thing that you can compute with and what
do we do we're like okay throw all that
out we're gonna just like dump it to
just the blah
bytes or JSON throw out all that type
information
oh yeah and we're gonna make you write a
bunch of boilerplate to actually make
that happen
and like okay why why do we do that well
parched it's partially for a good reason
so we want to be assured that when we go
to read that that information back later
we want to be assured that it has like a
well-defined format that we'll be able
to get back something that contains the
same information about what was in the
original list of employee so you know we
maybe the notion of like what an
employee is may have changed between the
time we wrote it out and the time we're
reading it in and so we're like because
the notion of an employee may have
changed we need to sort of write all
this manual code and and do all the
stuff ok but this is really the same
kind of problem as the the diamond
dependency problem if we simply don't
allow if we don't refer to things by
name if we say that what an employee is
is simply like the hash of that of that
type that can never change so it may be
that the name employee is assigned to a
different a different type in version
two but we can always still deserialize
the version one notion of what an
employee was without any problem and
it's perfectly fine to have you know
multiple versions of what an employee is
floating around your code kind of for
the same reasons I already talked about
so this gives us like a really nice
story for like defining like reliable
durable data structures you can just
just very straightforward like hey I
want to make this persistent and then I
want to be able to unpurchased it later
and you can do all kinds of neat stuff
with that
okay so last one here so let's talk
about distributed systems now
the basic idea we'll look at an example
here
just conceptual before I actually show
any unison code suppose Alice wants Bob
to a so Allison Babur two nodes in a
distributed system and Alice wants Bob
to compute something Bob go compute
factorial seven okay so except in unison
Alice is not going to send the name
factorial over to Bob she's going to
send the hash of factorial over to Bob
and Bob may say and so in that hash
uniquely identifies what function is
being evaluated and so Bob might say
like oh actually I don't know about that
that hash yet can you can you send it to
me and Alice sure here it is and then
Bob says great I've got everything I
need
I'm gonna go ahead and run that and then
Alice hears that result boom and Alice
keeps coming so this idea of having a
content or having a reliable identifier
that always means the same thing on all
the nodes in your system that hash that
sort of gives us this nice efficient
dynamic deployment protocol it's sort of
more generally it's like if you if you
know about Merkle trees it's sort of
like a Merkel if you take the dependency
graph it's sort of like a Merkel tree
dynamic sync operation and it can be
made very efficient very straightforward
okay so this also works so Alice and Bob
don't need to be like named you know
nodes that you've like set up in advance
either so it could be that like Alice
just conjures up a node from the cloud
or from this you know maybe it's a
cluster
of nodes that you're managing but the
point is like you haven't set up that
node in advance to have any code like
you didn't have to like oh set up its
class path and made sure make sure all
it had all the right jars blah blah blah
it's like it can just sort of start out
as this empty unison node that doesn't
really know about any definitions and
simply when you first contact it it may
do some dynamic syncing of code that's
needed and of course can be cached for
next time and so this sort of works for
defining elastic systems where you're
really just provisioning these more
anonymous compute resources and then
kind of just discarding them when you're
done cool so let's look at actually some
unison code for how this plays out
I'm defining a function here factorial
app takes in a node Bob I'm gonna say at
Bob go ahead and start computing
factorial seven the quote here is saying
basically don't evaluate factorial seven
here delay that and ship the unev alyou
ated thing over to Bob so he can start
evaluating that this returns like a
future so so at this point in the code
factorial seven is running on the Bob
node here I'm saying at spawn at a newly
conjured up compute resource start
computing factorial of an eight in
parallel and then maybe I'm going to
wait for those two parallel computations
to complete and then add them together
this is a really silly example I admit
all right let's look at the type two
because it's kind of important it's so
you see this these funny curly braces
attached to the arrow so in order to get
access to the at spawn and force
operations we need to tell unison
that in its in the types we need to say
that hey we're okay with remote stuff
happening in this definition and if we
were to like delete the remote from here
unison would complain it would it would
say like hey you're trying to do
something that requires the remote
ability and your types don't give you
access to that here so we still have
nice types to kind of keep track of
things and like prevent you from getting
mixed up about you know when when things
are happening that you want to keep
track of here's like a little bit this
is the distributed sort of a toy
distributed merge sort implementation
looks a lot like a regular in-memory
merge sort you're dividing the list in
half
you're recursively sorting but both
halves and then you're merging the
results the only certain difference is
that we are the recursive sort call
we're doing that in parallel on two
different newly provisioned compute
resources okay so what I mean this
interface to distributed programs it's
like this seems like the dream I mean
there's no JSON there's no opening
Network so it's just like you just wrote
code and you just kind of annotated
where you wanted concurrency and
distributed execution to occur and then
you know what is it just magic like
what's what's going on here okay so the
and this is we're working on this right
now but the idea is that distributed
programming should just be a library so
we don't we don't you don't think that
we are going to have all the answers
about what is the right abstraction for
building distributed systems and so
Remote is just anyone can define these
we call them abilities where you just
define a set of operations the at force
and spawn and then with regular units
and library code you can define
different interpreters that handle these
operations so
one of the things you might do is is
have one interpreter for these
operations which just runs everything
locally maybe it even simulates failures
and injects latency things like that but
then you could also have another
interpreter of this ability that you
know attached the computation to an
actual source of Elastic Compute and
actually was running it for real and
parallel on lots of notes and the idea
is like you should be able to write
these libraries just just as well as we
can and it's really the only things that
the Unison language needs to provide are
some of those primitives for doing like
the the serialization of computations
and syncing and things like that and
then you could sort of build up your own
you know protocols and abstraction zand
and I'm like super excited to do that
and also to see like what other people
will come up with and very very exciting
so these just just I just want to say
that the this the things that I showed
here that just this really simple remote
ability is really this is more for just
like batch computing so it's like you
essentially have a pure program like
it's it's something that in principle
you can run just as a regular purely
functional program just on your one
computer it's just you're saying like
hey it would be nice if my laptop were
actually a supercomputer and I could
just have access to as much compute as I
wanted so that's certainly a useful
thing you know for doing things like
data science machine learning you know
lots of things are just batch computing
but the other I think the other really
interesting use case in distributed
systems is when you have these steep
more stateful elastic services where you
have lots of concurrency and but then
the system is sort of coming to some
consensus or agreement about what this
state of the system is so this would be
something like you're implementing a
some sort of key value store and it's
you know massively parallel you know
tons of updates happening concurrently
on all these different nodes and like it
would be great if you could write
services for for that kind of thing in
unison as well and so this is sort of a
topic of ongoing research there's a lot
of interesting research that's like
happening in the distributed systems and
functional programming communities
that's sort of I mean we really want
something that's nice like that's as
nice as that that sort of batch
computing thing we're like so yeah just
trying to this is active area of
research and I think it's super exciting
and yeah I'd say in the next six months
or so you know we'll start to see more
about kind of what what that API could
could look like so yeah that is the end
of my talk so let me just say a few
things first of all thank you
I will also want to say thanks to just
all the open source contributors who
have like contributes to unison and
helped get it to this point if you're
interested in helping out with the alpha
testing if you go to unison web org and
you'll you know just follow the links
there it'll sort of guide you to the doc
site and then tell you about how you can
get started and then other thing is
we're having just an informal
get-together at the sliced pint at 6:00
p.m. after the conference ends today and
feel free to come by and say hello and
have some pizza or drinks and we'll any
last-minute coordination we'll do in the
hash unison and channel on the strange
loop slack so I think that's it all
right
you